this is a ginger delight and here we've  got cumberland sausages and cheesy mash  gravy  it looks like a massive dog's turd on  the mashed potatoes  cheesy mashed the kind of stuff you  serve to four year olds not heroes  and this is a a ginger delight  delight it is nice and light you can see  visually it's actually cooked quite nice  the slicing could have done better in  fact it tastes way better than it looks  so the person that i'd like to have on  my team would be the person that  cooked the cake jerry  the person who made what do you say  pancake dimash punky dimash  bangers bangers and mash  yes yes yes martin no disrespect but  thanks